I Am Naturally buff I Am Naturally buff
I Am Naturally buff I Am Naturally
buffed
[Music]
all right so how do you guys train
training I just do calisthenics uh
weightlifting as well weighted
calisthenics that's my favorite but I
did call the static stoop before dude
that's what's up yeah extreme volume
extreme intensity not like every split
pretty much I've done like push-pull
Arnold split but I do bro split I just
do like isolations yeah I just got back
into the gym so five days a week so I am
a power lifter um it's pretty low rep
pretty high intensity right now I'm kind
of like in my off season so you you
would compete in powerlifting yeah does
anyone else compete with you no no yeah
I've never done this before I will say
about it but no I will say that I
compete in USA government which is like
drug tested so I can't yeah
I mean and I do high intensity low
volume that's how I found I gained the
most muscle about a year ago I was 120
pounds again like 50 pounds of muscle in
six months dude you're definitely
juicing
I'm just telling you the truth why would
I say that if I was using how much do
you weigh right now 165. how much is
that one way I'm 165 as well I'm like
195. yeah I weigh like 180 185 it
depends I went out drinking last night
so I don't even know what I'd wait last
time I checked was about 185 to 190 ish
you uh you you strike me not at all the
calisthenics and stuff so like you're
off my radar at least yeah yeah
stereotype is kind of like the natural
like hard-working way exactly yeah like
the athlete X yeah guy you know yeah
that was a fraud though anyway
I'm 27. I'm 23 27 19 24 24 26.
people see like sea bomb or like all
these big bodybuilders as teenagers like
you want to be like them yeah right so
you're gonna think like the fastest way
to get there is juicing do you guys
think that like the little kid Tristan
liaison juice
good like year round at all times
probably if you're enjoying this video
like And subscribe and let's get back
into it
I could immediately really tell when I
saw Tyler that I was it was the
shoulders I was like this is a big guy
trying to hide under like a bigger shirt
[Music]
people have always been suspicious but
it's just how I look I guess it's not
really up to me it's really up to the
person can I take 20 seconds to clear
myself because I think I can yeah all
right so I've been living for like only
a year I started out like my first six
months vegan I'm pre-med at college so
like I support others taking steroids
but I personally would never so I'm
basically I'm focused on health and I
think it's contradictory to hop on juice
so you guys can question me all you want
because
telling the truth okay how about instead
of questioning you just look at
physiques sure take off our shirts
yeah it's kind of weird to say that but
let's just do it it's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you are pretty you are worthy you are
enough hey sorry to interrupt are you
okay I don't know I've not been feeling
too well lately I think social media is
really getting to me I feel you I had to
delete my Ig have you tried talking to
somebody about it not yet
I think even the thought of finding a
therapist is so overwhelming have you
heard of today's sponsor for this video
better help better help makes finding a
therapist super easy you can find the
right therapist for you regardless of
limited options in your area to get the
help and support that you need oh wow
this looks great I just filled out a few
questions and it says that I'll be
matched with a professional therapist in
as little as a few days
that was so easy I feel a weightlifted
already whether you have a clinical
mental health issue you want to address
or you're simply a human in this world
who's going through a hard time therapy
can give you some great tools to
approach life in a different way
consider online therapy with better help
to get 10 off your first month of better
help click the link in the description
or visit betterhelp.com Jubilee media
thank you to better help for supporting
this channel now let's get back to the
video
I'm very against it I think for yourself
or just in general in general yeah I'm
very health conscious so I would never
consider it so it's more the health and
like cheating or like taking shortcuts
and also the cheating as well I don't
believe in uh kind of taking the
shortcuts of things in life so what
about you no never thought about it no
okay never thought about it I'm gonna
like touch it and hear it no I thought
about it only because like every
powerlifter like everyone wants a squad
like a certain amount like if you're
going to compete in like a competition
where everyone's lifting like 800 pounds
but no I don't really have an aspiration
too and I'm also scared of needles so
I've definitely thought about it I mean
you see Larry Wheels like benching 700
or something yeah but like I'm not gonna
act on it why not the health I think so
yeah also my parents would kill me
what's everyone's like educational
background I'm going to my second year
of college pre-med chemistry okay so you
notice how to use a needle I do yeah
what do you guys do for a living I make
like Fitness YouTube videos okay so you
have uh you have like an incentive I do
have an incentive but I also have a lot
of people watch me that has uh that
looks up to me so have you made a video
that you're Natty
I mean it's pretty obvious about my
videos that I am daddy do you watch them
like I'm like always like below average
performance wise in that yeah so yeah I
don't think it's always obvious because
there are a lot of people that I know
especially like influencers that like
you've seen in real life they don't even
look like they work out
what are all your bench press Maxes the
most I've done is 215 but I'm going to
try 225 soon hopefully join two plates
thank you uh 365.
265 or 275 okay yeah mine is weak mine
is like 315 okay yeah 275 I have
shoulder problems so I can like rep 225
on incline but I can't wait
275 275 flat yours is like 315 like like
powerless just like one one
[Music]
all right
I was suspicious of Damon just because
he was also pretty built and he had
those traps he had the shoulders and he
also seemed a little nervous too so I
kind of uh figured that he was trying to
hide something
Moves In The Box with you raise your
hand on three one two three
we voted out the like biggest like
strongest looking guys I feel like 19
year old and like you've bench press
like a lot then also I kinda
when I was 19 like trust me I didn't
look like you you know like thank you
I'll tell you that was a problem yeah it
depends on muscle mass like 50 pounds to
gain within that short time of you
lifting yeah it's a little suspicious I
mean I was I was vegan for the first six
months realized that I couldn't put on
like or I couldn't maintain that muscle
and so are you still vegan no I'm eating
chicken I don't eat red meat just for
health reasons it's crazy because even
being vegan that would even be like
harder to me like acquire but if I don't
eat red meat would I take steroids you
have a medical background so you
understand it better which means you
know how to do it safely because there
is a safe way to take steroids
technically is there if you know what
you're doing I mean I know the dangers
of it too like we researched that
exactly you know the dangers so you know
the right way to do it in general I'm
very against steroids I don't think
anyone should take it I think there's
some people that do take steroids
because they want to compete in
bodybuilding but a lot of those people
fail to see the long-term downsides of
taking steroids and that it will impact
your health most of the time you guys
targeted me a bit you guys both didn't
raise your hands so you're confident
that everyone in here is natural but the
youth did a razor yeah yeah but then
you're going towards me
I honestly think that you're not on
steroid Brendan because you know I've
done calisthenics before and this is
totally achievable like physique
um I don't think you are as well you're
just like a bigger guy but like you know
you just eat like a lot and then you
know a power lifter
but for you
um
what's up you know you're young you're
like
trying out new things I don't know like
a lot of young kids are like you know
trying to get into like Fitness
best results because see everyone's arms
is that okay just go like this sure
I'm just looking for IV marks because
you get a lot of IVs you tend to have a
hole
show yours
sometimes they go in the legs right yeah
I mean I'm just looking for like actual
Ivy to get tested right
[Music]
like salty sweet because it felt like a
compliment you know they think I'm on
steroids only been working out for a
year it feels pretty good if you think
that there's still a mole or maybe even
both moles in the box there with you
and you want to keep playing raise your
hand on three one two three
confident
all right the Box turns red that means
one or two of the moles are still in the
box and they will split the cash prize
if the Box turns green that means there
are no holes in the box and u3 when they
cast prize
one
[Music]
two
two three
one or both moles could have still been
in the Box are you guys ready
the moles can sit forward on one
two
three
[Music]
and Bowls won they get to split okay and
that's where you guys Stacks are well I
mean I'm just on tests right now but
I've done a little stuff here for sure
so I tell everyone guys stay natural the
biggest goal in the life is to live my
longest and live the healthiest life but
um if you're gonna do it do it safely do
it with someone who knows how to do it
do it who's someone who's done it for
years and years on end so you could do
it the best way possible but always stay
natural honestly man chicks don't even
like it they like a Calvin Klein looking
guy like you know they don't like the
big Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle looking
guy like me so I don't know much about
parallelism but I know that they all
love orals
foreign
I hopped on steroids right after my last
competition I was competing in
powerlifting naturally Squad at 600
deadlifted 600 and then I wanted to hop
into bodybuilding so I contacted my
coach and I was just kind of like hey I
want to win let's really go for it and I
got into contact with my doctor my coach
my nutritionist all that kind of stuff
just to make sure everything was good to
go can I get to take my shirt off
because I want to do the post thing no
it's okay no I'm just
okay if you want me to I will yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
he
should have tipped the whole cash prize
but I got half so
[Music]